the 36 year old groping allegations
against Brett Kavanaugh fall apart the
economy soars to new heights and
Democrat Senator mazie Hirono needs a
fainting couch then the one and only Ken
Starr joins the program to discuss the
special counsel his old employee Brett
Kavanaugh and just how wicked the
Clintons really are even worse than you
think finally the mail bag I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Noel's
show
all right we've got to have the daily
Kavanagh allegation update I guess
that's all we do now that's all any show
can do is talk about not credible
allegations from 40 years ago about what
a teenage Brett Kavanaugh did so this is
all falling apart as I predicted by the
way I would like a little credit here
let the record show I never took these
allegations seriously and they're even
less serious today than they were
yesterday or the day before so we've had
a couple people come out and say I know
I went to high school with them and I
know that these are real and then the
second anyone asks them a question they
say I would never mind I take it back I
take it back so that's not gonna work
the the woman Christine blase Ford said
that she was going to testify before
Congress and then she didn't do that and
then now they say they want an FBI
investigation why I don't know I
couldn't tell you what the FBI is going
to do well there the FBI is just gonna
go to the Oracle at Delphi and they're
going to say so Oracle tell us what
happened at a party that may or may not
have even occurred 36 years ago they're
gonna rub the crystal ball it's all
thank goodness the federal government
possesses this crystal ball to let us
know what happened so that's obviously
frivolous and absurd the Democrats first
said that we need to hear this woman we
need to hear this woman the Republicans
don't want us to hear this woman and
we're gonna hear her or else and then
the woman said I'm not going to testify
she said how dare those Republicans try
to bring this woman to a hearing how
dare they how insensitive she should
never speak before a hearing so it's all
all frivolous but I would like to give
out for the first time ever on this show
you know we're almost near awards season
now we had the Emmys over the weekend
and a month or two we'll get into the
film Awards I want to give out the not a
very serious person award the first
annual not a very serious person award
for her performance in the fake Brett
Kavanaugh allegations that would go to
Hawaii Democrat Senator mazie Hirono
Maisie come accept your award guess
who's perpetuating all of these kinds of
actions it's some man in this country
and I just want to say to the men in
this country just shut up and step up do
the right thing for a change
you see I'm a little upset by this you
know mazie Hirono setting women back
hundreds of years where would you like a
fainting couch man would you but the man
I hate the man and it's all the men's
fault it's okay it's okay you're there
there there there it's okay step up and
do it change for once she says by the
way so first of all now all men are
assailants or rapists or whatever
according to this frivolous woman but
then then she says men should step up
and and do something good for once for
once as though men have never done
anything before I would like to point
out not not to I I don't really believe
in this sort of sexual conflict that
mazie Hirono is bringing up but just to
answer her point we know that men have
stepped up and done great things before
we know this even in recent history the
evidence for that is that if American
men had not stepped up and acted
courageously and done the right thing
then mazie Hirono and all of the other
American women would be speaking German
right now if they were even allowed to
speak you know every every great war you
know all of the defense of our country
running the government starting me yeah
there were a lot of I think men have
done okay I think they've done okay over
time amazing hero knows men men
wah-wah-wah-wah all of the arguments by
the way that have ever been made all of
the sexist chauvinistic arguments or
that you know women are more prone to be
emotional and paint with a broad brush
and you know that that's why they can't
be in public life and then mazie Hirono
just goes that i hate all the men well
and then but then that actually isn't
even the least serious thing she's she's
done all day she goes on and someone
asks her okay you're saying that these
allegations of Brett Kavanaugh against
Brett Kavanaugh are are fair they're
real we should believe them what could
Brett Kavanaugh do to prove them wrong
and to exculpate himself here's what she
says about what if anything could judge
Kavanaugh stay in this yearing that
would convince you that he didn't do
what he's accused of he is saying that
he didn't do it what else can he say so
I set that aside and I look at what dr.
Ford is saying and we've all said she
makes a very credible claim so nothing
you can do nothing
what could Cavanaugh do to exculpate
himself well he nothing nothing he can't
say anything I don't believe anything he
said even though he has an unimpeachable
career in the public eye he's been a
judge for 12 years but yeah okay I don't
believe anything he said but then a
woman who refuses to testify to speak to
anybody on the record no witnesses the
only witnesses that she can even muster
up say it never happened calls it
absolutely nuts that's the woman that we
have to believe that is not a serious
person mazie Hirono but it's also not a
credible allegation you heard that word
did you hear that she said that at the
incredible these are credible
allegations she's a credible accuser and
this is a point on language that I think
we all need to pay attention to you know
they say brevity is the soul of wit so I
try to always use an economy of words
and when I write things and I bring this
up a lot I did a Praeger video on the
importance of language Democrats pervert
the culture and pervert our politics by
twisting language and we let them get
away with it they just say slogans that
are not true that distort reality that
pervert reality and we let them get away
with it sometimes we start using that
language too and that's over time
perverts the culture so I'd like it
pointed I wrote a column on this a few
days ago I talked about it on the show I
never thought the allegations were
credible even if the woman's not lying
or even if she's misremembering or what
I'm just saying the allegation itself is
not credible why because there's no
evidence for it it was made well after
the fact in the heat of a political
moment no witnesses the story has
changed nothing about it is credible the
Democrats have insisted from the
beginning it's a credible allegations
credible it's credible when we see this
now they've got their talking points Dan
Pfeiffer who's on one of those Lefty
podcasts he's an old Obama bro he tweets
out quote credibly accused sexual
assailant Donald Trump put incredibly
accused sexual assailant Brett Kavanaugh
in the Supreme Court tells you
everything you need to know about the
Republican Party mm-hmm
now what is credible mean here what it
was credibly accused Donald Trump paid
off a porn star apparently he paid off
some other model or something
I don't think stormy Daniels has accused
him of assault I don't think
any of the other public people have
accused him of assault there are a lot
of accusations that are surrounding a
lot of these people but where is where
is the credibility what what is grand
obviously the brick haven't I think is
absurd from susan kenedy
fantasy at CNN quote it is worth
pondering that if this doesn't make a
difference and good money says it won't
two of the nine justices of the US
Supreme Court will have been credibly
accused of serious sexual misconduct
what a statement to the women of this
country now she's referring to Clarence
Thomas who in 1991 same exact thing
happened he was about to go through and
at the last minute they sprung up some
allegation of sexual harassment by a
woman named Anita Hill even though I
need a hill it worked with him for a
long time there had never been tours
were open they've never heard anything
about this I couldn't get good witnesses
on it they totally railroaded him and it
really damaged his reputation needlessly
Brendan Nyhan who's a New York Times
contributor quote imagine the reaction
to future Supreme Court rulings on
women's rights if two of five justices
in the majority and the president have
been credibly accused of sexual
misconduct credibly accused credibly
accused credibly they got their talking
points today but that tweet sums up what
this is really about
because likely Cavanaugh is gonna get
through I don't see how he's not gonna
get through and a lot of insiders are
saying within a week truly there's gonna
be nothing left to this allegation but
what they want to be able to do is once
Cavanaugh is through be able to run for
the rest of his life and say oh Cavett
he was accused of sexual assault he's a
rapist he's a rapist I mean there's no
no evidence for any of that at all not
even in the accusation but that's what
they're gonna run on especially when it
gets down to abortion questions and and
Cory Robb and a lefty writer wrote quote
if Cavanaugh is confirmed that means
every 5-4 opinion authored by the courts
conservative majority will include two
men credibly accused of sexual
harassment if that doesn't call into
question the legitimacy of the
institution and the rule of law blah
blah blah blah blah he's underlining all
of this he's saying haha we're about to
undermine the legitimacy our of our
institutions which they've been doing
since 2016 and then Paul Krugman Paul
Krugman former Enron adviser Paul
Krugman writing in The New York Times
quote once upon a time catching a
Supreme Court nominee in a pretty
obvious lie at the same time he's being
credibly accused of other deceptions
probably have been disqualifying but
this is the modern GOP Paul Krugman a
member of the party of Bill Clinton John
F Kennedy
FDR Ted Kennedy all the Kennedys Anthony
Weiner keith Ellison okay okay buddy
sure the thing that so we need to pay
attention to this really closely because
when you hear this language I think a
lot of times people hear credibly
accused credibly accused it's on all the
news shows and they'll just say it
they'll just spout it if you're a
Democrat if you're a moderate of your
centrist even some Republicans credit oh
it's credible credible credit no no no
that was just made up they pulled that
out of thin air a Democrat
communications firm which is likely
advising that the party is involved here
he said okay you got to use this
credibly and well if they do this with
videos whenever we have evidence of
Democrats being degenerates on video
they say oh it was a heavily edited
video video is edited by definition all
video is edited you started at a certain
place you ended at another place you
upload it you put it somewhere all video
is that if they say heavily edited as if
to mean untrue and they're saying
credible accusations as if to say these
are true allegations and there's no
evidence for that at all you've got to
pay careful attention because while
we're talking about this well we're
debating this this is the this is a
worse part of the whole situation is
they they have us playing on their
territory so I think we've got to just
put an end to it make this vote happen
get past Kavanagh get past this
nomination because the the actual
headline today is that unemployment
joblessness has hit a record low it is
at the lowest level that it's been since
1969 that's under the economy of
President Donald Trump what else has
happened or stock market has hit a
record high the Dow jumped 250 points
today why is that because investors are
not worried about the trade war that the
Democrats told us was imminent that was
on us right now
and sober Republican said is not a real
worry the economy has never been better
it has never been better things are
going great in this country and they've
got us arguing about a 36 year old
allegation where the woman can't say
where it happened why it happened who
was there she changes her story it only
comes out at the 11th hour
she won't she wants to testify she won't
testify we're talking about that
nonsense that pure fiction that they
have crafted when we could be talking
about the real economy around us the
real political achievements of this
administration and they're trying to
play that for the midterms we should we
should stop it stop all this nonsense
give us give us a vote put him on the
Supreme Court and move on because things
are going very well I have I'm very very
lucky to have one of the great figure is
probably the most famous lawyer who
isn't on the Supreme Court in the
country a figure from all of our
childhood Ken Starr who has he employed
Brett Kavanaugh and a lot of the players
actually who were in in the news cycles
today he's been a judge he's been all
over the place in politics and he's got
a new book out contempt about the
Clinton administration and the a special
prosecutor investigation is the
Independent Counsel investigation the
Monica Lewinsky affair and on and on and
on Ken Starr joins us to discuss his new
book and everything else going on in the
news all of which seems to involve him
judge Starr thank you so much for being
here my great pleasure thank you for
having me on so judge story you have a
unique vantage point I think in DC as
you have held just about every important
role and every role that we're seeing in
the news cycle right now DC Circuit
Court of Appeals judge Solicitor General
Independent Counsel where you employed
Brett Kavanaugh professor university
president Chancellor now the author of
contempt which I very very much enjoyed
I urge everybody who is a political
junkie to read it and not just that
anybody who is confused by this news
cycle to read it because it explains a
lot of things that even I couldn't quite
put together and also for Millennials I
know a lot of Millennials watch the show
judge story you are a central figure in
our childhoods you were plastered all
over television for all of our
childhoods so to begin I want to begin
with the job itself and then we can use
that to go into the news cycle Cavan on
and all of that there is a difference
between an independent counsel a special
counsel and a special
prosecutor you very famously served as
independent counsel during the Clinton
administration and you write in the book
that when you were offered the job you
didn't think the job should exist you
disagreed with the law that created the
job so tell it tell us about that about
the job and how it fits into our
constitutional framework yeah
and the constitutional point is very
important but it's also very important
at a practical operational level so it
has both theoretical importance and
practical importance under the
Independent Counsel law I was appointed
to serve as special prosecutor later
named independent counsel as the law
that Congress passed as amended by three
judges to conduct an investigation of
the President of the United States
Bob Muller our current special counsel
in the news is appointed not by three
judges but he's appointed consistent
with the traditions of our country and
our law by the Attorney General of the
United States are in this instance the
acting Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
I've learned that distinction of who
appoint and then who ultimately can fire
uh and who can guide and supervise wise
all the practical and constitutional
difference in the world I did not like
the statute under which I was appointed
because I felt and continue to feel that
the appointing Authority for executive
branch functions such as prosecutions of
possible federal crimes should come from
within the executive branch all is
really responsible to the president
the issue has always been for how much
independence should this outsider
brought in to conduct an investigation
of the President or those posts around
him or her have and what the Independent
Counsel law did was to say we want
greater independence less of a
connection to the Justice Department
we're not going to cut the Justice
Department out of the process entirely
so my final point I was appointed by
three judges but at the request of the
Attorney General under the law Janet
Reno who is President Clinton's Attorney
General so under the statute the
Congress passed in 1978 is a post
watergate scandal reform a special
division of judges was set up they would
do the appointing but they rolled into
operation only at the request of the
Attorney General so under the statute
passed by Congress in the wake of the
Watergate scandal a law passed in 1978
three judges had the appointing power
but they rolled into action only upon
the request of the Attorney General who
had information that oh something needs
to be looked into an Independent Counsel
should be appointed but I the Attorney
General can't do the appointing and so
the three judges on this special panel
asked me to serve so let the record show
as we stand along I didn't volunteer for
the job but I was asked to serve and I
did sir that's how I feel about my job
as well as I didn't volunteer for this
all this abuse here at the Daily wire so
on that point because that really does
clear things up I think a lot of people
see these terms and they don't see the
distinction the distinction between who
appoints whom and where this falls III
I'm not I'm not asking you to be too
much of a political pundit but as you
observe the Muller investigation all of
the accusations from both sides from the
President and from Democrats and from
the left how do you think the
investigation seems to be going should
it wrap up are there calls for it to
wrap up should it keep going on past the
midterms how do you see it so far I
think Bob Muller is doing his job and I
have encouraged the president to leave
him alone stop using I know exactly a
good good luck yeah did you tweet it to
him yeah that maybe that might that
might
send the message but no I I wanna I'm
booked I love my country
I want my president to succeed whether I
agree or disagree with the president I
want the president to do a good job and
one of the messages in the book is that
if you see I campaigned to demonize the
prosecutor guess where that started it
started in the Clinton years and in fact
the Trump team has been reported to say
we're just taking a play from the Bill
Clinton playbook demonize the prosecutor
and do everything you can to stand in
the way
deny delay and so forth now that having
been said from what I have read
Bob Mahler notwithstanding all the
rhetoric and all the tweets has enjoyed
the cooperation of the president and the
president's team there's a huge issue as
soon as the president going to be
interviewed or not but the interview of
the president if it happens would come
only toward the end of the process so
now to come back to your basic question
I think Bob Mahler is if anything he's
winding down in terms of the
investigation of collusion now what we
don't know is whether the Attorney
General here the acting Attorney General
rod Rosen Stein has expanded Bob
Muller's investigation we know of course
that is investigation immediately took
him to Paul Manafort right and so there
weren't just questions involving George
papadopolis my general Flynn which had
to do with the possibility of
connections with the Trump campaign with
Russian operatives or Russian interests
getting the guilty plea recently this
last week from Paul Manafort is enormous
ly helpful to Paul Manafort
I - mr. Muller yes mr. Muller - Bob
Muller for obvious reasons not only to
save time energy resources and so forth
having to go into trial trials role
is uncertain you never know what's going
to happen but here's the key point
Bob Millar now enjoys the full
cooperation least that's what's called
for into the agreement Paul Manafort so
that helps get to the bottom of the
whole issue of Russian collusion let me
well okay I've seen no evidence of
Russian collusion I know about the we
all know about the Trump Tower meeting
in June of 2016 but I think that's been
pretty much flushed out and no charges
have been brought at least thus far
against anyone on the basis of that
meeting and I want to return to what you
mentioned the the Bill Clinton of it all
the the Clinton playbook of it all
because reading your book I really love
it it's a trip down memory lane for me
to my childhood and I'm seeing all of
these characters crop up again rot
Rosenstein crops up a lot of other
people who we see in politics and of
course the Clintons and Hillary Clinton
in particular you don't paint a great
picture of them including in the title
of the book contempt how much of this
owes to the Clintons how much did the
Clinton administration and their
handling of your work in particular but
obviously other issues too how much did
that poison our politics and lead to our
currently
toxic political environment I think it
contributed to what President Clinton
himself called the politics of personal
destruction politics is a tough sport
right James Stewart the Bueller
surprised winning author of a book
entitled bloodsport about the whole
whitewater of fear before the trials
began in Little Rock and our 14
convictions guilty pleas and so forth
but what the Clintons did was to treat
people with contempt for example monocle
when treated with contempt right it
wasn't just a denial it was he was the
stalker
she was narcissistic I mean there are
different allegations and accusations
made against her Paul of bourbon Jones
who brought a sexual harassment lawsuit
that sounds pretty familiar right a
sexual harassment lawsuit against
President Clinton for his
actions that she likes occurred in
Arkansas during the time he was governor
well wanted huntin surrogates say the
most demeaning thing she's trailer-park
track and you imagine that
and yet the culture was coarsened we
think the culture is some of us have
concerns about the directions of the
culture but I will say this I was done
that Bill Clinton personally and the
people around Bill Clinton but demonized
women who had had either a consensual
relationship with the President or in
the case of one eat abroad wreck a very
colorful allegation that she had been
raped and I mean raped by William
Jefferson Clinton when he was Attorney
General the state of Arkansas and one of
the things that I don't say in the book
even though I praise so many people in
the press yes I praise so many people in
the press is being truth seekers and one
of those crews I'm gonna have to ask you
about that afterward but please go on
okay what yeah what yeah I'm sure I'm
going on shut me up and I think that
true no no please and Kooten well thank
you included Lisa Myers of NBC News who
first uncovered the story of the alleged
rape and NBC News would not allow that
to air now think of it now especially
with social media now remember this is
the time when some pretty famous and
powerful people other than Bill Clinton
we're doing some very nasty things and
the workplace right and all these things
are now coming out and and and and I
think it's a healthy thing now I'm going
to say this especially in light of the
Brett Kavanaugh situation I believe in
Brett Kavanaugh I totally respect him
I've known him for so many years he was
with me at my side during many years of
the investigation we practice law
together and I think the outpouring of
support for him suggests that we are a
long long well he just absolutely denied
that this
alleged episode ever happened with this
person or with with with anyone anyone
anywhere but you're so right it's one of
the messages of the book I think we've
grown up in certain respect as a couple
and that question of the media and of
Cavanaugh because I suppose you're right
I suppose I can agree there are some
some members of the media who are truth
seekers though it's hard to find them
these days and I remember even as a kid
the media destroyed you I mean they
targeted you you went from being
criticized by Republicans as a squish as
being too moderate to being this
right-wing rock-ribbed knuckle drag
within two days because the White House
turned its attention on you in the media
followed suit we're seeing this all the
way up through a judge Cavanaugh now
judge Cavanaugh has a lift with his
apparently unimpeachable life this that
you know we should all be so lucky that
the worst our enemies could drag up on
us is this story heard for the first
time 35 years later but what is the
media's role in all of this has that
media role changed did it change under
the Clinton administration or have they
always been Bulldogs for one political
view over the other for the Democrats
over the Republicans yeah I have a more
benign view of the press they're always
going to be bad apples are gonna be
partisans who have journalistic journal
one my drives date credentials all right
so they have credentials hey I'm a
journalist I'm with newspaper X or media
platform why but I'm very Jeffersonian
about this so Jefferson hated the
Federalists dominated press and was
eager for more anti federalist
newspapers to get started and so forth
and yet he wisely knew we've got to have
the Free Press we've got to have an
aggressive Free Press so all I say is be
careful who you're listening to
assessment but always ask the question
and am i hearing the truth am i hearing
facts or am i hearing spent and what the
and every White House says it's probably
and operation I understand that but what
Bill Clinton did with his operatives the
James Carville's at the time to George
Stephanopoulos and so forth those folks
were masters at the art the evil and
dark part of spinning a narrative but in
the process I don't think Stephanopoulos
ever do this but Carville definitely did
he made sport of attacking people and so
didn't Hillary Clinton Bill Clinton was
much more elegant about it obviously
he's naturally charming and charismatic
guy I pay tribute to his many political
gifts in the West but Hillary is cut
from a different cloth she turned her
back on her upbringing in the suburbs of
Chicago when she went to Wellesley she
became a radicalized you say oh that's a
terrible thing to say no as I described
in the book she became a follower and
student of Saul Alinsky the author of
rules for radicals and what is one of
the rules for radicals no not rules for
Christians rules for thoughtful
secularists rules for kind a theist
rules for radical and wants one of the
key rules of radicals attack and destroy
mm-hmm attack and destroy and lie lie
lie on in the book you talk about how
she was so brazen in saying I don't
remember I don't know I don't recall I
don't remember that you considered
charging her with perjury III if I'm
getting that right you got a right and
thank you for noting that because you
know part of the meta-narrative is host
I found nothing in Arkansas and then
went after the president because of a
private consensual relationship so we
all know that narrative even if you were
a child you now know I mean that's just
part of our modern history right totally
wrong and so one of the reasons I wrote
the book my memoir is to set the record
straight
to complete the records and here is a
fact not fiction and I spent 14 criminal
convictions in Arkansas and then most
relevantly in light of your comment we
seriously considered going before the
grand jury a little
Rock Arkansas in the spring of 1998 it's
a and died Hillary Rodham plug but we
made a professional judgment that we did
not have the evidence sufficient
evidence to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that she committed these offences
so she was a very lucky person she
should be down on her knees thank yous
that image at night saying thank you
dear Lord that for what I did that I was
not prosecuted by the Independent
Counsel absolutely and that image of
Hillary Clinton on her knees praying I
don't how does the does the saying go
the angels take care of their own or I
don't know it's a dead baby it's a
different thing than that I don't know I
don't know who she's praying to exactly
I think the angels take care of drunks
and lawyers that's right
but and it's a-you know throughout the
book I love that you continually return
to what is the truth we are after the
truth everyone you're speaking to Monica
Lewinsky whoever it is we're after the
truth and it's something that maybe
there isn't enough of these days so I
really encourage people to read the book
because you know I think a lot of us saw
it on TV and we were told a certain
narrative of what happened and and those
issues are still affecting us today and
it's it's important to get that record
right judge story I've taken up far too
much of your time so I'll let you go
thank you so much for being here though
I really appreciate it
oh great pleasure and thank you for
promoting the book it's in many respects
it's the cry from the heart about our
country and how good our country is and
that our system of law does in fact work
it can be quite ugly a time but ugliness
is not our system of law the ugliness is
the human condition the human being in
our system but our system is very
structurally sound may we keep our
system of a constitutional republic
dr. Franklin asked us to do that on
Constitution Day September 17 1787 may
we continue to guard and love our
constitutional republic amen Ken Starr
one of the most insightful people in our
public life so we've got a lot more to
get to we have a whole mailbag today and
I'm gonna I'm gonna get through all of
them probably I want but I'm gonna try
to get through all
so if you are at daily wire calm thank
you very much you help us keep the
lights on in Co FFA in my cup if you
were on Facebook and YouTube get out of
there man get over to daily wire it's
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
Klavan show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you test questions in the mailbag like
the one that's just coming up you get to
ask questions in the conversation you
get everything you get everything that
you could ever want
most importantly the leftist here's
tumblr you get the mazie Hirono tumblr
you but the man it's the men very very
good Thank You senator Hirono the go to
daily Morecambe we'll be right back with
the mailbag
let's jump right in from our room dear
dr. Kofi Feng I often hear my leftist
acquaintances of Caucasian descent say
check your priveledge to each other what
does this mean I honestly have never
been quite sure what to make of this
ridiculous phrase could you please
explain it and deconstruct it for me
yes it means shut up check your
priveledge means shut up that's the only
way that it has ever used that's all
that it implies that's the only action
that is requested by that phrase check
your priveledge means shut up it means
you have an opinion that I can't refute
or argue against so I'm going to on the
basis of your race or your sex or if
you're a man who thinks he's a man or a
woman who thinks she's a woman tell you
to shut up so shut up that's what it
means the reason that it's prevalent
among left-wing circles is because
everybody's got to serve somebody and
leftist politics is a jealous angry God
which will have no God before it so it
replaces religion you know we've talked
about this with environmentalism
environmentalism global warming has all
of the trappings of religion it has
original sin and in the form of
pollution
it has indulgences in the form of carbon
tax credits yet there are works that you
can do there are you know there are
things that you can do to bring yourself
closer to the God mother nature Gaia
whatever you want to call it earth day
whatever this is also true in the check
your priveledge in the intersectionality
politics of identity race sex whatever
which is that when they walk around and
say check your priveledge it's a sort of
inversion of maiya colpa Mia culpa mea
Maxima culpa you know when you begin a
mass you call to mind your sins and you
say have sinned I confess my sins to you
my brothers and sisters please pray for
me to the Lord our God in in this case
you're flipping and you're saying you're
a sinner you're us you're bad you've
committed the sin of being white you've
committed the sin of being a man you've
committed the sin of being a man who
thinks he's a man you've committed the
sin of being a man who's attracted to
women
and so it's an inversion it's a it's
angry and you know it's not very
charitable it's not very graceful it's
not very loving but it is a feature of
the
of leftism and you should ignore it it's
stupid it's ridiculous I never I'm kind
of lucky because I'm I'm just swarthy
enough you know I don't know where I
fall in the privileged scale i but you
would even see this sometimes I think
people in colleges for instance who come
from financial aid you know my family
did not have a lot of money and I was on
financial aid and I would notice this in
college anyone who's a Republican this
pilloried is being rich or coming from a
lot of money or whatever and the impulse
is to say no I didn't I didn't come from
a lot of money I came from humble
backgrounds I've had tough things in my
life I think it's a huge mistake I don't
think you should do that you should
never engage with those hateful
arguments if you get into a fight with a
skunk it doesn't matter if you win
you're gonna end up smelling very very
bad don't give those premises away don't
acknowledge the privileged thing just
laugh at it laugh at it move on from
Zachary dear Michael Corleone Al Pacino
look-alike Knolls hooah
big man excuse me I recently had an
argument to prove God prove God to a
friend of mine and the question came up
that I really couldn't answer so I'll
pose it to you if God can see the future
and knows how it goes
why create anything in the first place
it's an interesting question that this
hasn't occurred to me and it is worth
noting you can't prove God you can make
arguments for God but God is the basis
of all meaningful speech so it sort of
begs the question even those arguments
but there were good arguments for God
there's a lot of evidence for God the
question is why would you create
anything at all if you know how it's
going to end how else could you create
anything what are you talking about any
artist who creates a work of art knows
how it ends by definition because he
creates the art so he creates the ending
of it he's out of court if you're
outside of time and space if you're
outside of creation then you know about
creation you know everything about
creation but what what work of art would
you create where you didn't know how it
ended could you write a novel and not
know how it ends could you make a movie
and not know how it ends could you paint
a picture and not know how it ends not
know everything about it of course not
Myra the relationship between God and
man
and is similar to the relationship
between Shakespeare and Hamlet but
Hamlet is the creation of Shakespeare
he's outside of the book Shakespeare
knows how Hamlet ends I won't spoil it
for you if you haven't read it but of
course I I don't I don't see that
objection at all in fact that objection
seems to me a good argument for God as
we know God and there's a there's an
extra part of the story because then the
creator enters into the creation enters
into the story and makes the greatest
story ever told but you got to read you
got to read past the first chapters to
get to that part from Spencer o Knowles
who knows how do you think we can
maintain a sense of purpose whether as a
society or as individuals if we reach a
point by technological advances advances
that will render work largely
superfluous Spencer we won't because
we're creative human beings are creative
and so there's never a point at which we
won't want to work Adam in the garden in
perfection was given a job and he worked
it is in our nature to work when people
don't work they atrophy and fall away
and die they spiritually and sometimes
physically that now does that mean that
I'm gonna at some point there won't be a
robot that can clean my house yeah
there's probably gonna be a robot that
can clean my house that's great because
then I can work on other things like not
writing books maybe you ask the wrong
guy this question but even if there is
certain work that is automated that will
just create other work because we are
creative people and this is when people
talk about artificial intelligence they
say speak of the human mind is if the
human mind is just a computer that only
exists to solve problems presented to it
that is such a misunderstanding of the
human mind the human mind is creative we
are made in the image of God the Creator
and we are creative we essentially
create there there is no robot that is
going to stop me from creating or stop
my impulse from creating that's that's a
it you know in a very essential way what
makes us human from Patrick to Knowles
at all the other day I overheard someone
who calls themselves asexual freethinker
asking why consensual incest is wrong it
was made very clear that he doesn't put
any stock toward religions teaching on
this and our moral viewpoints should be
challenged on a regular basis
by an honest and unbiased viewpoint he
also mentioned that the argument for
preventing the mental and physical
dysfunctions brought on by such
relations was a eugenic one and would
effectively close off certain people
from reproducing because it would likely
result in the same thing this is this in
mind how would you argue against this
line of thought thanks and love to show
Patrick what is unbiased thinking tell
me what unbiased thinking is what what
moral vision does not take into account
metaphysics morals aren't a physical
thing I can't this isn't a moral well
leftist ears have a lot of moral value
but they're not morals themselves and
morals aren't a physical thing they are
metaphysical things so when we discuss
morality we discuss metaphysics which is
in the realm of philosophy and theology
and religion so if he says I want to
discuss metaphysics without discussing
metaphysics then he's a dumb-dumb and
should realize the error of his ways but
to the question itself
why should consensual why is consensual
incest wrong this has cropped up in a
lot of news stories some teacher just
got fired for asking this question to
his students this has come up in a
number of colleges and philosophy and
psychology classes why is it wrong well
you can't I suppose you can look at
physical evidence which is that the kids
are more likely to have disabilities and
dysfunctions in them but even ignoring
that why is it wrong in itself let's say
that they used perfect sexual protection
you know pills and prophylactics and
this and that the other thing just the
Union itself why is that it's because it
is an attack on the family it attacks
familial love it is unnatural it is
against natural law which does exist and
when we talk about natural rights we
talk about human rights the only way
that human rights and natural rights
make any sense is if we talk about a
natural law from which we can to which
we can associate them so it is wrong now
what is the if your friend says he
doesn't want a moral argument for why
it's immoral then I can't help him very
much but if he's asking for something
that is beyond the realm of metaphysics
the only help I could give him is
something that leon kass who's a
terrific bioethicists genius out of
UChicago he wrote out an essay about
this probably 20 years ago about the
wisdom of
and I'm not saying that this should be
the entirety of your argument for why
incest is wrong but this might be a good
starting point if you don't want to rise
to the higher levels of philosophy or
theology or whatever which is that there
are certain things that we just feel to
be wrong we feel it is wrong to watch a
boy murder his grandmother you know or
sleep with his sister or we see assaults
on the family is wrong why is that it's
something built into us certainly and
there are two ways of approaching this
it seems your friend is approaching it
and saying well if I can't it rationally
explained right now with his apparently
limited rational faculties why it's
wrong then it can't be wrong and then
there's another way of approaching it
which is why do I feel this way why does
it seem to me into every great thinker
ever that this is wrong
perhaps they were on to something it's
Chesterton's fence there there are two
reformers you know you if you drive up
in the middle of the wilderness and you
see a white fence just right in the
middle of nowhere one type of reformer
says I see no reason for that fence to
be there pull it down but the wiser
reformer says before you pull that fence
down you need to explain to me why that
fence is there it when you explain to me
why that fence is there then you can
tell me why we should pull it down and
this is the case with an issue like this
and it's a broader point on politics
this is something that the left and
right differ on because I think and I'm
firmly on the right I think that I could
explain most of the views most of the
opinions of the left most of my friends
on though I've got a lot of friends on
probably most of my friends would call
themselves left wingers and I think that
I understand and could explain most of
their opinions and I think they could
not explain most of my opinions that
should tell you something you should be
able to understand the other point of
view before you refute it we still get
some time from our room I bet that's the
same Arun I don't think there are a lot
of our UN's watching the show dear dr.
Co FFA should we it's definitely the
same one should we grant citizenship or
permanent residency to immigrants who
express consistently anti-american views
in public like taking in me or calling
America racist both my parents are
immigrants from India
and on the rare occasions when people in
our community disparage America or the
flag it bothers us that they are
denigrating the country that gave us
everything we have again the sentiment
is rare but should people with these
views be permitted to become citizens or
should they just be judged on their
economic merits thanks and may your cup
overflow with Coe FFA yeah we should not
allow those people to become citizens if
you don't love the country you should
not be allowed to become a citizen if
you're already a citizen that's too bad
I guess you know we'll have to deal with
that but absolutely not but there are a
couple points of view on this the one is
this total open borders just you know
make an idol at a free trade and what
would be called globalism or imperialism
which says yeah if you can add to our
GDP by point zero zero zero two percent
who cares if you're a Nazi come on into
the country who cares if you hate our
country who cares if you want to
undercut our country and there's another
view that says no in order to join the
country you have to love the country you
have to love what it's about you need to
support it you need to know something
about it you need to be brought into it
that is the view people who don't love
America should not be permitted to
become Americans it's as simple as that
and if they're here already and they're
not citizens
butum out get him on the next boat send
him home from Andrew hello to the Daily
wire representative from the Vatican my
question concerns had to deal with
selfishness in a relationship I've been
single my whole life so I don't have a
horse in this race sorry to hear that
but my friends and their partners all
seem to be focused on what they can get
out of the relationship and not about
the other person I was wondering what is
the best way to quell these selfish
tendencies also I could use some advice
on how to get into the dating game as
I've not yet participated in it for all
18 years of my life thanks love the
superior daily wire podcast you have
good taste sir it I find this is in to
use conservative philosophy and public
policy and economics it's very easy it's
much easier to channel one's bad
tendencies into a good tendency than to
just try to stomp them out altogether so
my argument for why you shouldn't be
selfish in a romantic relationship or a
marriage is that it will hurt you that
hits that you're ultimately being self
sacrificial or altom
being self-destructive if you do that
selfishness in a relationship will
poison the relationship it will poison
your life you will be miserable you will
not you will look back on your
relationship and think gosh what a waste
of opportunity what a selfish little
Ruffy and I was what word am I looking
for a little bug that I was if you
really are looking out for your own
interests then in a relationship in a
marriage you should be selfless and then
you'll have a better time and your life
will be better and you will grow and
love and you will be have a smile on
your pillow every night and you will
wake up feeling joyful if you want to
look out for your own self interests in
a relationship don't be selfish
from Matthew good day mr. Coe FFA was
public speaking ever difficult for you
assuming someone is not naturally
charismatic how much of getting better
at public speaking is just practicing it
over and over and how much is it
conquering your fear of failure or worry
of what people think of you what is the
relationship between this experience and
this fear thanks big fan so I don't
remember too much about when I was a
baby but I have heard that I spoke at a
very young age I think I observe started
speaking at 11 months or something so
there might be a national natural
component to speaking publicly or being
comfortable speaking and so perhaps some
people are less naturally fit for that
than others but I think much more
important than that is practice and
training over time you know i've i
recommend acting classes to everybody i
think it's very helpful it helps you
understand characters it helps you study
the human nature it helps you
participate in an artistic field it gets
you better at speaking it gets you
better at knowing just the muscles of
speaking sometimes people on twitter
will make fun of me for enunciate
we're having precise diction i've i've
taken a lot of diction classes that's
just the way I talk you know and it's
good because then people can understand
you more easily so I think you can
overcome that very easily some of our
great orators had speech problems
Winston Churchill had a speech problem I
don't think Abraham Lincoln was you know
from the age of 2 just spouting off and
listening to the sound of his own voice
I don't think he was doing vaudeville
shows or anything like that it can come
with
practice and and with practice then you
have to have been you gain and
confidence but it is a muscle it's a
muscle like anything else a little a
little pro tip here if you're ever doing
a university play or something like that
I think a lot of people when they're
trying to memorize lines they just read
them in their head so they'll have the
script up and then just read them in
their head and you won't that you won't
memorize lines very effectively that way
the way that you most effectively
memorize lines is to say them in a very
exaggerated way so you know for a
question you could say dear Michael
president cough FA dot that that that
and you do that because there is a
certain muscle memory and you'll and it
will trigger other things people e in
our culture a lot of people just want to
have a rationalist view of everything to
have everything abstracted and in the
ethereal realm but you got to put it
into your body and when you put it into
your body it'll become a lot easier for
you as for all right I'll get to I'll
get to that and I'll get to the the next
part of that if it pops up in another
question from Kyle Michael I'm in
college and there are a few girls in my
classes that I'm interested in dating
switch colleges dude one of the reasons
why I haven't asked one of them out is
because I do not have a car I could call
an uber to pick her up walk take the bus
or have her drive us I don't do this
because I feel like it is my traditional
responsibility to provide the
transportation the real answer here is
me Manning up and asking one of them out
but then it comes to what is the most
proper way for us to get around town
thank you and I can't wait for your next
Valentine's Day conversation Kyle don't
worry about it you're in college don't
worry about a car I never had a car in
college I didn't have a car when I lived
in the city I wouldn't worry about that
depends if you're gonna go to a bar or a
restaurant or something that's near
where you and she live then you can walk
I think that's perfectly fine or take an
uber taking ubers are great because then
you can drink a lot and not worry about
killing somebody that's a win-win the
this though does get to a point that
I've talked about before when people ask
me for dating advice you're not going to
ask a girl out even if you like a girl
even if you think she's cute and you
think she's smart and funny or whatever
because you're worried that you won't
impress her by not having a car you're
just thinking about you forget about
that who cares what is it a bet is it
about you showing off to a
or isn't about you getting the girl get
the girl dude get the girl I hope that
helps I'll do one more one more I'm
sorry I'm doing it too bad from Marc
Michael your article here's all of the
evidence against Brett Kavanaugh is
well-written and informative it shares
the same level of precision as some of
your other books the product of a master
well done thank you out you're clearly a
scholar I'm glad that's a good question
to end on because it's not a question
it's just a statement and you clearly
have a robust wealth of historical and
political knowledge to draw on if you
could understand my article here's all
of the evidence against Brett Kavanaugh
I've got a great book that I can send
you okay that's our show we're gonna
show tomorrow because we didn't have one
on Tuesday so I will see you them in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show talk to you soon
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you
you